welcome to the show everybody most of
this show today is a little bit
different it's gonna be dictated by you
and your emails and because there are a
whole bunch of them a whole bunch of
emails of stuff that I've gotten over
the last few weeks many of them not
directly tied to current events and
thank God for that and I haven't had a
chance to answer a lot of them so today
for my only show of the week I want to
really back away from some of the news
and current events and everything and
just for today go through some of my
emails and topics that you have brought
up and and answer those but first the
one topic I'll bring up myself and I
have just a few things to say about this
there's been a lot of discussion
recently about vote by mail or mail-in
voting or vote from home as the
Democrats have christened it Democrats
want to push for mail-in voting and
spend billions of dollars to fund it and
Trump is against the idea and that's the
that's basically the the breakdown of
the the controversy here
the reason we're given for why we have
to do vote by mail is that of course
come November the coronavirus is still
going to exist and we don't want people
going out to the polls and getting
infected that's the argument way the
reason that Trump Gibbs for not wanting
mail-in voting is that there's an
opportunity for fraud because it'd be
very difficult to protect the integrity
of the voting process when people are
doing it at home and mailing in the
ballots now a lot of states already had
mail and voting that's a thing that
already existed but in many states you
can only do it under certain
circumstances like if you're elderly or
disabled and even the states that allow
anyone to mail and vote you know most
people don't do that now what we could
be looking at a potential situation
where you've got tens of millions of
mail-in ballots how do you keep track of
everything and and as I said protect the
integrity of the voting process now
here's what I'll say about that I also
am against mail-in voting I'm against it
in general though even aside from the
coronavirus or anything else I don't
like it but my reason has very little to
do with voter fraud yeah that is a
concern Trump is right but that's not
the primary concern I think when it
comes to the integrity of the voting
process and issues
two that have to do with voting voter
fraud is a much much a lesser concern
than something else that I want to talk
about and it's also true as others have
argued by the way that the idea that
voting will be significantly dangerous
because the coronavirus is totally
absurd I think we've established by now
that you can leave your home and you
should be okay you can go out and do
things and still avoid being sick you
don't need to be locked away in fact you
probably should not be not probably you
definitely should not be locked away so
it will be perfectly possible and really
not that difficult to have people go to
the polls in person and vote and not get
or spread the coronavirus I mean after
all it's not like people are going into
the booth you know as groups or at least
they shouldn't be so we're already
socially distanced when we vote so I'm
not really sure I understand what the
problem is but aside from that aside
from fraud as well and and aside from
the fact that this isn't even an issue
my problem is that voting shouldn't be
that easy
anyway this all goes back to the
fundamental flaw in the way that we
think of and approach voting in modern
culture we see it as this sacred
universal right held by everyone and so
we have to make it as easy and painless
and convenient as possible for people to
do it and any obstacle that's put in the
way any inconvenience that they suffer
any sacrifice that's required to them in
order to do it is seen as depriving
people of this right or at least
interfering with their ability to
exercise it now there are some problems
here starting with this voting is not a
sacred universal right held by everyone
in fact we don't treat it that way in
this country even now really we don't
let people under the 18 under age of 18
vote we don't let felons vote we do
obviously think that there should be
some parameters put in place to
determine who can vote at least most
people think that our founding fathers
thought that there should be even more
parameters now of course for a long time
in this country when women couldn't vote
black people couldn't vote and that
needed to be fixed and it was
that doesn't mean however that we should
have to do away with all of the barriers
and obstacles and parameters that were
put in place so yeah you do away with
the racial and gender based obstacles
sure but the original idea only property
owners vote that is only people with
skin in the game only contributing and
competent members of society vote that
was good
that's how it should be take away all
the racial and gender elements of it and
the basic idea is a good one
politicians especially Democrats though
want everyone to vote they want to make
it as easy as possible for everybody
vote they want to make it so that you
almost literally don't have to raise a
finger yourself lifts a figure to vote
if they could they could if they could
come to your house and carry you to the
polls like a baby cradling you in their
arms and and humming lullabies the whole
time they would do that if they could
why is it because they're just such huge
fans of the democratic process is it
because they just really believe and you
know having people involved no it's
because they benefit by having
uninformed lazy stupid non-contributing
people voting those people are their
people right that's their constituency
they they need those voters they don't
just want those votes they need them the
voters they don't want though are
informed intelligent mature I mean the
kind of voters that would be willing to
make a sacrifice the kind of voters that
will you know it's so important them to
protect them to participate that they'll
carve out some time on the actual day of
voting and go to the polls and do it now
these Democrats those are the voters
they don't want but they can't stop
those people from voting so instead they
drown out their votes in a flood of
stupid in a flood of lazy and stupid
that's why they want a big turnout
big turnout means that a lot more than
just the informed and interested and
invested people came out it was exactly
what they want and that's why well
everybody cheers for big turnouts III
hope for small ones much smaller ideally
there would be you know 10 or 20 million
people voting tops I mean they're really
invested the really informed the really
involved people and if it was just them
America would transform for the better
practically overnight in that scenario
okay we're gonna take a pause here to
check in with a new sponsor very excited
about ero you know it's it's it's
extremely frustrating and I think we've
all been there before I know I've been
there when your wife is being slow and
it takes forever to load especially for
me where I well it's a combination of
where I live and also what I do for a
living that I need a fast internet
connection but I don't always have it
until I got euro euro is Wi-Fi for your
that your home deserves blanketing your
whole home with fast reliable Wi-Fi and
not just inside but outside too I can go
out to my back patio and it's the same
thing
euro extends so you can enjoy the nicer
weather and get work done from your desk
wherever you want to be around inna
around your house euro will get their
hero eliminates poor coverage dead spots
and buffering will have a consistently
strong signal wherever you need it
euro sets up in minutes plugs right into
your modem or router you know it's very
easy to do if I can do it you can do it
so good this is a good good good way of
looking at life in general apple homekit
users euros got you covered as well with
enhanced privacy and safety controls
that give connected devices only the
permissions they need to do what you
want in your home and on the internet so
you get a lot of privacy there as well
it's just it's great to have and
sometimes you don't even know what
you're missing like you may not realize
how slow your Wi-Fi is until you get
euro and then you're gonna see you're
gonna really see the difference you can
get yours fixed as soon as tomorrow go
to eurocom slash Walsh and enter code
walls to check out to get free next day
shipping with your order that's e e ro
dot-com slash Walsh code wall should
check out to get your euro delivered
with free next day shipping you must use
this URL to receive this offer against
ero comm slash Walsh code wall
I have proposed before I'm not the only
person to propose it you know you have a
basic sixth grade civics exam as a as a
requirement for voting so if you were to
just I mean take everything else out of
it if you were to require sixth grade
civics exam taxpayer citizen ID and you
have to show up to the poll on the day
to vote leave all those five parameters
not very onerous at all that would rule
out the vast majority of the electorate
but the thing is those are all the
people we want to rule out right those
are all the people that have no business
voting in the first place if you can't
pass a sixth grade civics exam you have
no business voting in the first place
that's why I don't like mail-in voting
it just it makes it too easy I think it
should be a little bit more difficult I
think it should be harder to vote not
easier oh but you're advocating voter
suppression Matt yeah in a way sure I am
I am advocating voter suppression I mean
the type of voters who can be suppressed
because they're scared to go to the
polls eight months after a virus came to
America yes those voters I want to
suppress I want to suppress them by
forcing them to either make the
sacrifice and take the risk and go or
stay home if somebody isn't willing to
put in that minimal amount of skin in
the game then we don't need them don't
want them and and you know it's it's no
hard feelings and and no offense
intended if you're someone who wouldn't
think it was worth it to go out and vote
that's fine
Godspeed I don't judge you that's
perfectly fine I'm not one of these
people who says you're a bad American if
you don't vote yeah just disk you should
vote no it's ridiculous if you haven't
been paying attention if you don't care
that much if voting isn't really that
important to you that you wouldn't even
leave your house to do it then you you
and you decide not to vote I don't judge
you for that in fact not voting in that
case is the patriotic thing
because you are staying home rather than
inflicting your ignorance on the rest of
us which i think is selfless and
patriotic and it's the right thing but I
also think it should be forced that if
you're in that camp you just shouldn't
be allowed to vote in the first place or
you should be forced to put in some
effort that's everything I've just said
super scandalous these days now you say
this kind of stuff how dare you that the
idea that you would suggest that anybody
should be prevented from voting is
there's a scandalous I'm gonna faint I'm
so offended by it that's only because we
are such a stupid we have become such a
stupid country in many ways that we
would find what I have just said
scandalous when this was originally the
idea in the first place this is how it's
supposed to work
alright let's so there's that just
thought I'd give Media Matters a little
bit of fodder and that'll keep them busy
for half a day or so and now let's hear
from our friends at honey you know it
can be very daunting to search for
coupons for online shopping I've never
been a great coupon clipper never gonna
coupon clipper at all in-person and
online you know I I'm not really into
the coupons either at least when I have
to go and find them myself but with
honey it makes it easy even for someone
as dumb and lazy as myself the coupons
and savings come right to you honey
is the free online shopping tool that
saves you money online honey
automatically finds the best promo codes
and applies them to your cart it's as
easy as that
imagine you're shopping one of your
favorite sites you know Target BestBuy
Macy's whatever it is when you check out
this little box drops down and all you
have to do is click apply coupons that's
it box fly coupons wait a few seconds
for it to scan every promo code on the
Internet's and you just watch the prices
drop and you're just saving money the
money's racking up while you're doing
that honey has found over 18 million
members over two billion dollars in
savings so if you want a piece of that
pie and I would really recommend it
because I've been using honey I've been
telling you
on you for months now I've been using it
saved I can't keep track of how much
money I've saved that's one of the good
things I'm not you know I can't keep
track of things and so that's why I like
honey to do it for me not using honey is
literally passing up free money why
would you do that
it's free to use it installs in just a
few seconds plus it's backed by PayPal
so you know that you can trust it get
honey for free at join honey calm slash
Walsh that's join honey dot-com slash
Walsh will move on and like I said we're
gonna go to the mail bag a lot of
interesting questions and let's go right
to it from Luke says hi Matt loved the
show blahblah cutting to the chase I'm
dying to hear your take on James
Fairbanks yes James Fairbanks so this is
a fascinating case if and I know I said
we were going to be all beholden to
current events but I had I got to talk
about this because it is very
interesting if you haven't heard James
Fairbanks is the name of a man in
Nebraska who confessed to killing a guy
named Matteo Conda Lucci and Fairbanks
just walked into Conda Lucia's house
shot him in the head kill right pretty
clear-cut you would think the wrinkle
here is that Matteo was a convicted
pedophile so let me read from the
district Herald on this you need to hear
all the details because as I said
fascinating here's what it says the
real-life Dexter was only caught because
he wrote a lengthy letter to the media
explaining why he did it and vowed to
turn himself in as long as they
published it Fairbanks says that he had
been that he had seen Conda Lucy on the
sex offender registry while he was
looking at a house in the neighborhood
he was upset when he went to view the
home and saw the pedophile outside
looking at children Conda lucci 64 was
found dead in his home in Omaha Nebraska
on Saturday after being shot at his
front door on Thursday on Thursday
Fairbanks 43 was charged with the
first-degree murder and use of a deadly
weapon to commit a felony and a
confession email about the crime
Fairbanks a former Omaha public school
employee wrote that quote I've worked
with kids for years who've been
victimized and I couldn't in good
conscience allow him to do it to anyone
else while I had the means to stop him
the letter was sent to the various media
outlets anonymously and posted to a
social media the mother of one - Conda
Lucchese victims Loras
myth has even started a Facebook group
to support Fairbanks her son Anthony
took his own life after being sexually
abused by the pedophile when he was 5
years old
Smith has spent years trying to get
justice for her son who died from
overdose in 2017 okay so that's that's
the one hit what happened with that part
let's let's go into the details of the
pedos crimes because they really do
matter in 1993 Smith had moved in with
Conda Lucci she made a run to the
grocery store later late one evening and
when she came home she found her son
violently crying in the bathroom
I knew something was instantly wrong
Smith told The Daily Beast she said that
her son claimed he had wet the bed my
son has never wet the bed in his life I
ended up packing my stuff the next day
and when we were leaving my son quietly
said mommy I got something I got to tell
you and I instantly knew the child told
her that Conda Lucci had touched his
genitals and forced him to touch his
while fully clothed the child predator
pleaded guilty to attempted lewd and
lascivious content or lascivious assault
upon a child in 1994 and was only
sentenced to four years of probation and
drug counseling in 2007 Conda Lucci
struck again and raped a
thirteen-year-old girl he was sentenced
to five years in prison but released in
just over two because of quote good
behavior okay so that's at least two
molested children only two years in
prison between the two cases and we all
know that there are many other victims
aside from those this man was molesting
a five-year-old in 1994 his next
conviction was 2017 what do we think he
was doing in the intervening decade and
a half you know another important note
here is that the pedos own daughter says
that her dad was a monster and children
are safer now that he's gone and she
thinks that Fairbanks should only get
probation for murdering her dad so
that's the basic of it what's my take on
this right off the top I'm glad that the
pedophiles dead he deserved to die
he had it coming absolutely thrilled
that he that he's dead
thrilled by that no one on earth should
shed a tear for this monstrosity
obviously and it sounds like his own
daughter isn't what does that tell you I
mean when you die in your own children
call you a monster and say that the
person who killed you shouldn't go to
jail I mean that that just if we didn't
already know it from his crimes that
that that confirms you as a as a just
top of the line scumbag right now on the
other hand I also think that the courts
can't explicitly condone vigilante
killing they can't come out and say hey
you know it's okay to kill pedophiles
obviously I mean that would be anarchy
they can't say that but if I were in
charge this man would not spend a day in
jail not one single day you know I'd
give him community service probation
call it a day here's the way I look at
it you know this is this is a matter of
justice right so what is justice in this
case what is justice for this man for a
Fairbanks
well the pedophile molested a
five-year-old child you know a
five-year-old and I know that I don't
need to explain why that's a horrible
thing but it's worth stopping to think
about this just for a moment think about
the mentality okay of a man who looks at
an innocent five-year-old child and sees
in that child a thing an object to be
used sexually think about the depths of
evil of just utter spiritual darkness
and desolation required to see a
five-year-old child like that and then
to act on it and so he does even molest
the boy ruins the boy's life
and then when he's what was at 19 he he
dies of an overdose that was a boy whose
innocence needed to be protected and
instead this piece of filth this human
garbage this animal took that innocence
took it and even if the death didn't
come you know for another 15 years he
took that boy's life too he killed him I
mean
murdered him and yet he gets no jail
time no jail time probation so let me
ask you if you can pay your debt to
society for molesting a five-year-old by
serving probation then what debt does a
person Oh for killing the month the
molester who does that that's the way I
look at this the pedo got no jail time
for molesting a five year old two years
for raping a 13 year old so then what is
killing that pedophile worth could it
possibly be a greater crime than the
mullah stations themselves no way I mean
sick for Fairbanks to get a harsher
penalty than the pedophile himself got
for preying upon two children at least
would be a enormous miscarriage of
justice there's no way that we could
call that justice I don't know I know
people are uncomfortable with the idea
of you know we got to punish vigilantism
but that cannot be you cannot claim that
that would be justice I think justice
here is looking at the pedo sentences
and using that as your baseline so if he
got a total of two years and I'm the
judge I'm looking at that and I'm giving
Fairbanks I don't know six months of
probation or you know even half a day of
community service
I'll have him go clean up the side of a
highway for four you know six hours on
some Tuesday then send him home so his
neighbors can throw him a party have a
barbecue so that way you know you've
technically convicted him you haven't
explicitly condoned vigilantism but also
your being just and you're being fair we
should also highlight I mean it mentions
it in the article but according to
Fairbanks he says that the thing that
ultimately got him to act was that he
you know was outside and he talks about
this in detail in his letter that he
said and he posted on social media which
you can go read if you want to but he
says he saw this guy outside in his
driveway just like staring down some
children that were in the street playing
and so
Fairbanks knew okay that this guy is
going to continue to victimize children
and the justice system had two cracks at
him did basically nothing and so he
decided if I don't do something he's
gonna continue to victimize kids and so
I'm gonna do something I'm you know that
that's courageous I mean that's heroic
what if you were in that position and
you didn't do what Fairbanks did which
most people would not but if you didn't
do what fair race it would be would it
be because you you know you you think
it's you you you you think it's wrong to
be a vigilante and and that's why you
refrain or would it be because you just
be afraid of doing that you don't want
to throw your life away my point is the
thing that would stop most of us from
doing what Fairbanks did isn't because
of ethical qualms as much as we might
claim what really would stop us is just
that we don't want to put ourselves in
that situation now before we go any
further I wanted to tell you about
ancestry DNA I don't know if you have
you've had a chance to do this yet but
if you haven't you really got to give
this a shot and I've done this myself
and it's been really incredible to learn
so much about your family history you
learn where you came from what your
roots are learn how you ended up the way
you are for better or worse really now
you may be familiar with the major
events and battles of World War two but
there are so many more stories to
uncover the skill and bravery of the
Tuskegee Airmen and all African
Americans squad of fighter pilots the
incredible women who trained to become
pilots and mechanics I mean all of these
all these many different stories you
know I mean and if you if you pick up
just a book on World War two and read it
sometime there's all these stories that
they didn't tell you about in school in
honor of the 75th anniversary of the end
of World War two ancestry has just
released a US draft card collection from
World War two with over 36 million draft
cards completed by fighting aged men the
United States across the country during
that time whether they ended up serving
or not there's a great chance that you
could find your relatives in that
collection and it can help you learn
more about what their lives were
and if you had a relative that served
and and sacrificed for us it's a great
thing for you to know uncover your
ancestors personal details in our world
war to us draft card collection which
shows details like home address physical
description and so much more I cannot
recommend this enough if you haven't
done it you're missing out ancestry.com
discover your own untold stories and
more head to my URL at ancestry.com
slash Matt to discover to start
discovering your story today that's
ancestry.com slash meant by the way one
other thing here there is some precedent
there have been cases like this through
the years let me mention just one one
case of a dad I don't remember his name
off the top of my head but there was a
dad in the eighties famous case his son
was kidnapped and raped by the sons I
think was his karate instructor and they
caught the rapist and they were bringing
him you know they caught him in some
other state they brought him back on a
plane to the stand trial in in in his
home state and the dad was was waiting
and there's there's video of this very
famous video the dad was waiting at the
airport with a gun for his son's rapist
to show up and as soon as his son's
rapist walked by him and he was cuffed
and he was surrounded by cops the dad
turned around shot on point like in the
temple killed him that dad did not spend
I don't think spend one day in prison he
had a suspended sentence and probation
now you know I look at that and I think
that's that was the right move I don't
think that father should have went to
jail I completely understand why that
father did what he did and so I think
it's a very similar situation I think it
should be treated the same way and I
bring up that case in the 80s because
anyone who says well if we don't come
down hard on this guy it's gonna be you
know it's gonna be anarchy and
vigilantism everywhere well this was a
case it's like 35 years ago and that the
father faced basically no penalty
legally and have we been living in an
anarchic hellscape ever since no all
right from Claire
says Matt I'm a fan but I've heard you
speak many times about the show Breaking
Bad and you've given it very high praise
I finally took you up on your
recommendation and I have to say I was
pretty surprised by the show and
disappointed in you I didn't expect the
content to be as objectionable given
that you as a Christian are recommending
it especially as someone who has
criticized Hollywood so many times for
the filth it puts out I didn't think you
would actually recommend that filth well
hi Claire
if you're gonna call Breaking Bad filth
and I don't know what exactly to say to
you I never said the show was
family-friendly I never said that it was
PG you know I never said it was
something you'd find on the Disney
Channel and it is about a chemistry
teacher who gets diagnosed with terminal
cancer then becomes a drug lord right
that's like in the synopsis of the show
so you had to know what you were getting
yourself into you were you expecting
Kirk Cameron to pop up the show is most
certainly not filth it is very poignant
absorbing fascinating it's a study of a
man's descent into evil it by no means
condones the evil or glamorizes it see
that's what filth does there's a lot of
Hollywood filth and I do talk about it
but the filthy stuff the filth the
garbage is the stuff that glamorizes and
condones what is degenerate what is evil
what is perverse there's a lot of stuff
like that in Hollywood Breaking Bad does
not do that I you know if you watch
Breaking Bad I don't think you'd come
away from that saying you know what I
really want to be a drug dealer quite
the opposite if you if you had any
thoughts of being a drug dealer I think
that something like Breaking Bad would
very much dissuade you so there's a lot
of moral complexity to the show which is
exactly what you don't find in so much
of the Christian entertainment which you
know I don't mean to make assumptions
but I'm assuming that's the kind of
thing that you're that's more your speed
which is fine but I just don't I don't
think I would say Breaking Bad is far
more edifying even as a you know TV ma
show with with violence and and drugs
and cursing I think it's far more
edifying than watching like you know
God's not dead
or some thing like that you know one
seen that and I've mentioned this before
and it's a good in season three or four
so you probably didn't see it because
you were storming off and a huff before
this happened but there's one scene
where Jesse who's Walt Walt's right-hand
man has just murdered somebody in cold
blood at Walt's behest you know just
just kills me and now he's overcome with
guilt and grief but what he finds and
that happens like at the end I think
it's a season three and then season four
picks up and and you know he's Jesse's
guilt ridden over this horrible thing
that he's done but what he finds is that
things start working out for him a lot
and you know he's making a lot of money
from the drugs and he gets away with the
crime and life is good seemingly but the
fact that life is so good makes him even
more guilty and so he's dealing with
this the entire season there's a scene
towards the end of the season finally
where jesse is at a support group a
Narcotics Anonymous type of support
group and he launches into this
monologue partially sort of confessing
to the murder in a roundabout way
but you know it's like a three or four
minute monologue in in the course this
monologue he's he's basically crying out
to be punished crying out that he's a
bad man he's done horrible things and
and he should be punished for it and the
fact that he isn't being punished makes
him feel like life has no meaning and
there's no purpose it's a tremendous
scene and there's great moral depth to
it it's very very much like the kind of
thing you find in Dostoevsky like it's
it's very Crime and Punishment
and there's a book that you probably
wouldn't like because it's brutal and
violent at points I mean the book starts
with the protagonist murdering an old
lady okay but it's also a spiritual
masterpiece and one of the best
Christian works efficient fiction ever
written hands down and there's only a
few other competitors and one other is
written by Dostoevsky himself so my
point is that scene in Breaking Bad and
so many other scenes are exactly the
kind of thing you will not find in any
Christian movie or any Hallmark show
they can never pull that off
they could never manage those depths
yeah God's not dead really like they
make an attempt at something like that
with their with their one of their you
know they got a couple atheist
characters in the show or just who were
total cartoons just one dimensional just
cartoons not not human beings you feel
like you would meet in real life and
they make an attempt to show the kind of
guilt and emptiness that you find in
from from living a nihilistic life they
don't even come close to what a show
like Breaking Bad is able to do but you
rule all that out because it's not PG
and it deals with serious things and
there's death and there's pain and their
suffering and there's evil and not
everything works out perfectly which is
like no real life I don't know I feel
like stories and the shows we watch
should have something worthwhile to say
about the actual world we live in
it's okay to have some escapism that's
it's got nothing to do with anything but
but the stuff that's really good and
meaningful is gonna have something to
say about the real world that we really
live in and but you I don't know you you
you rule that out and all I guess you're
right that's fine but that doesn't make
you a better Christian or me a worse one
and I'm not sure why you'd be
disappointed that I have good taste
anyway let's take a let's let's take a
sidestep here for a second I want to
tell you about ready wise this is as
good a time as any the best time of all
to really start thinking about if you
have enough food to last you in the
event of a real food emergency it's like
having an insurance policy you know we
have insurance for our homes and our
cars and we have life insurance we have
all different kinds of insurance what
about food insurance that's that's
something maybe maybe we don't think
about as much as we should our sponsor
wise company recently changed their name
to ready wise now is a better time than
any to be prepared with long term
nutritional food options ready Wise has
many options like emergency meals
freeze-dried fruits and vegetables for
convenient on-the-go d'etre
new adventure meals for hiking and
camping other outdoor activities
ready wise meals are easy prepare all
you got to do is add water and they have
a very long shelf life as well and
here's the great thing about it and I've
had it myself I can attest to this ready
wise uses the finest ingredients and the
latest food preparation technology to
ensure optimal taste and freshness so
you're getting prepared and you know you
have all that going for you but there's
no reason why you have to give up taste
there's no reason why it has to taste
bad and with ready wise it definitely
does not this week my listeners can get
free shipping at ready wise calm when
entering Walsh at checkout or by calling
eight five five four seven five three
zero eight nine ready Wise has a 90 day
no questions asked return policy so
there's no risk taking the initiative to
get yourself and your family prepared
today that's ready wise re ad Y Wis
EECOM promo code Walsh to get free
shipping today this is from Courtney
says hey there Matt I'm a big fan of
your show i watch everyday here lately
my husband and I have had some difficult
conversations about all of the
government mandates and there's one
thing we just cannot come to an
agreement on there's a lot of talk about
forced vaccinations and us being
Christians we want to do what is right
in God's eyes the issue is that my
husband believes that it is the right
thing to do to take the vaccines if the
government mandates them because as
Christians the Bible mandates that we
follow the laws of the land I disagree
with him knowing that I know knowing
what I know about Bill Gates in the
vaccine industry we have an almost
two-year-old daughter and I believe that
it is my god-given duty to protect my
child should Christians comply with
mandates like this or should we push
back against a tyrannical government
that wants us to force wants to force
something like this on unwilling
participants some advice is appreciated
given that the Bible doesn't directly
address this particular issue god bless
okay Courtney by the way I'm sniffling
so much out of allergies just so you
know it's not coronavirus this is this
is a tough time to have allergies you
know because people just people look at
you like like you're like you of leprosy
this is part of part of the burden that
I carry having that having a case of the
sniffles is a is a very significant
cross that I carry anyway
Courtney um so here's my take on this I
I don't think the government should
should mandate it I I think you
be morally justified in resisting the
mandate because I don't think the
government should be in the position of
forcing people to inject things into
their bodies just flat-out period right
but I also think that if you decide that
it's best to take it and comply that's
fine too I don't I don't think you're a
bad Christian either way I think either
approach is consistent with Christianity
as long as you're following your
conscience I just don't I don't think
this is one of those things where we
could say well if you're a Christian
this is what you should do with the
carnivai respect scene I you know it's
it's it's not one of those things that
is necessarily a moral absolute but
here's here's the rub I suppose follow
your conscience and you are obliged to
follow your conscience God gave us a
conscience to be an arbiter in these
kinds of situations not the arbiter okay
not the final arbiter I'm not saying we
we have the final and ultimate say over
what is right and wrong but we are in
arbiter you know our conscience is in
arbiter and an important one that God
gave us because it's right not not every
issue that you're gonna encounter are
you gonna be able to pick up the Bible
and find chapter and verse and well
here's where it covers the corona virus
vaccine right there that's just not
gonna be the case and so they're gonna
be plenty of plenty of situations in
life that you've encountered already
plenty of them I'm sure well you just
have to think it over talk about it pray
about it decide what what's best for you
and your family this is one of those
things this is from James says dear Matt
beards are ugly and yours is ugliest of
all you know what James I'm not even mad
at you for that I'm not mad
because you are a baby-faced freak and I
don't I don't mean that as an insult
it's just it's just what you are
scientifically and baby-faced freaks are
naturally envious it's it's part of your
nature and you see men of great
testosterone and great hairy net
you see in us something that you could
never attain and so you lash out because
you're hurting you're hurting I get it I
understand that I'm not mad at you for
it I'm not I will pray for you I will
pray for you you sniveling bastard let's
see are we gonna go this is from Tim
says Matt you guys are past your
lockdown but mine is still ongoing I've
been bored to death these last two
months wondering if you have some good
ideas for beating boredom I know you
talked about fishing a lot but there's
no lakes nearby I'm not really into it
anyway what else do you do when you have
time to kill honestly Tim I don't I
don't know what that is I don't know
what boredom is I can't remember the
last time I was bored maybe I was 12 is
the last time I was bored I I don't know
what it is to be bored so I couldn't
tell you how to beat it I I accept that
there's no excuse to ever be bored you
know it's easy for me to say right now
because I got four kids and so you know
for young kids they don't really allow
for boredom in the house but even if I
did it I mean I lived alone as an adult
for half a decade and I don't remember
ever being bored
I just can't how yeah I know what the
lockdown there's not as much to do but
there's still it's you've got an entire
world an entire life I mean there's so
much with every moment that you could do
or try or think about even or you know
in so many books too there are way way
more books to read than there are hours
in the day to read them so me even that
maybe you you could set to your mind
that for the next five years with with
every extra moment you have you're just
gonna read books and that would be a
very fruitful and fascinating way to
spend your time and there'd be no reason
to be bored there either because you
would never get through all of the most
interesting books you would even get
close so I just don't get it even if you
live for a million years people and I
and I don't mean to pick on you but you
hear this fried
I hear this from adults all the time
about how they get bored if you meant
for a million years I would say there is
no excuse to be bored even in a million
years considering how much there is to
do as a human in the world but
considering we only live for like 85
years tops and you're getting bored I
don't get it
I don't get it so how do you beat
boredom just like do anything do if
you're bored in a lockdown that I assume
you don't have kids I'm just that's
gonna assumption I'm gonna make and if
if that assumption is correct
I mean cheese man like just do go go
anywhere do anything that's my
suggestion let's see okay this
Matt why do you think that religious
liberty is good it goes against Catholic
doctrine because the only true faith is
the Catholic faith and showed it's so it
should be the only religion allowed now
granted religious liberty is only
allowed when it will cause public strife
and unrest in a country this is the case
with the USA and so would not work with
it but as a Catholic you should not be
advocating for it forgive me if I'm
wrong but that's what it seems like okay
I'm trying to follow your logic here
Vincent I think you well you are wrong
is there's no reason at all why there's
there certainly nothing in Catholic
doctrine I assure you that rules out or
condemns religious liberty quite the
opposite
so as a Catholic you should certainly be
in favor of religious liberty now if
what you're trying to say is well as a
Catholic then you believe that
Catholicism is the one true faith and so
what good is it to give people the
freedom to be in the wrong religion I
guess that's where you're going with it
but yes as a Catholic I believe that
Catholicism is the one true faith of
course if I didn't I wouldn't be
Catholic but I also believe that I
believe in free will and in order for a
choice to have any meaning you have to
you have to choose it has to actually be
a choice and so that's that's where
freedom comes in we have to give people
the freedom so you know what's what's
the alternative you know you could have
like a theocracy and force everybody to
be Catholic but what good is that
they're forced to it's it's it's not
authentic it's not chosen you can't
force it into their minds and their
hearts and even if you could you
shouldn't I mean God doesn't even do
that he could and he doesn't God
obviously believes in religious liberty
if God wanted to just force everyone to
know the truth and believe it he could
but he doesn't because we have free will
and so that that I wouldn't be in favor
of that now I say that I know it's a
little confusing because I of course I'm
kradic fascist but as I've said before
for that part of it as a theocratic
fascist it's more like the concentrate
more on the fascist end of that because
when I'm dictator
you know the theocracy part will kind of
come and go according to my whims I will
just govern by my wins so putting that
aside know I don't really believe in a
theocracy because for that reason you
have to be able to choose and I think
everybody should choose truth but they
have to choose it or otherwise it has no
meaning but thanks for the question and
I think I got through a whole stack of
them here so I think that's pretty good
we spent more time than I thought on the
James Fairbanks story but that that is a
very interesting story too to follow and
thanks I've word for for sending in the
emails and again if you become a daily
while remember you can have access to
all the different mail bags and you can
get a hold of us that way that's gonna
be it for me for the week I will talk to
you next week have a great week
everybody Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
our supervising producers are Mathis
Glover and Robert Sterling our technical
producer is Austin Stevens edited by
Dani D'Amico and our audio is mixed by
Robyn Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 Joe Biden informs 40 million
black Americans that if they support our
president they ain't black is Joe Biden
a racist is Joe Biden a rapist
democratic representative Ilhan omar
says she believes the woman accusing
Biden of sexual assault but she's going
to vote for Biden anyway and president
Trump accuses MSNBC's joe scarborough of
murdering a staffer some heavy stuff to
start the week check it out on the
michael nul show
[Music]
you
[Music]